and i'm eric sean
this is a fox news rundown
wednesday september 2nd 2020 i'm jessica
rosenthal
american cities are reeling from police
shootings protests violence
and a debate over supporting law and
order or supporting protesters
you know i think it's going to lead to
our ruin as a country if we don't have
some law and order again
i'm dave anthony millions of americans
might get a pay raise
this week but there's a catch the tax
cut in quotes might have to be paid back
next year they would need lawmakers in
congress to come to a deal
on a bill and put that bill forward in
order to make these
payroll tax deferrals permanent and i'm
jimmy fella
i've got the final word on the fox news
rundown
president trump traveled to kenosha
wisconsin to see the damage
meet with small business owners and law
enforcement following the police
shooting of jacob blake
during protests of that incident a
teenager shot three demonstrators
killing two of them
president trump said despite the damage
in kenosha law enforcement got the upper
hand
unlike they have he says in other cities
violent mobs demolished or damaged at
least 25
businesses burned down public buildings
and threw bricks
at police officers which your police
officers won't stand for
and they didn't stand for it these are
not acts of peaceful protest but really
domestic terror the president said he
coordinated to send in federal law
enforcement
and if other cities accepted similar
help and pressure
things would calm down while wisconsin's
governor activated the national guard
he declined the president's offer of
homeland security agents
but did later accept additional federal
support from the fbi and u.s marshals
one car dealership alone says it
sustained one and a half
million dollars in damage in kenosha
ricky talapatra told the president
he's been able to save two of his
downtown businesses but
says he also represents the downtown
kenosha incorporated organization
right now we need is financial support
uh loss of business and loss of
property is staggering at this point the
president said he would be giving
four million dollars to small businesses
in the town and one million dollars to
law enforcement in the area you know i
think we need law and order
i think the fact that our cities many of
our major cities are on fire
and that there's looting and marauding
and rioting in the streets i think is a
real problem for the country
rand paul is a republican senator for
kentucky i think it's important to note
that the majority of these cities are
run by democrat mayors governors that
are democrats
democrats have run these cities for 50
years and basically
they're a disaster chicago's a killing
zone
portland is on fire so i think the
president being there
lending moral support is a good idea as
far as
money we don't have any money in
washington we've uh
you know we're basically printing it up
and borrowing it as fast as as they can
possibly do it
and there are ramifications to spending
money you don't have so
as far as offering money don't know
about that but i do appreciate the
president offering more support
and also supporting law enforcement
because i think it's a tough time
to be in law enforcement it's difficult
to
try to corral you know wild people
lawless people that are roaming the
streets but if we don't
uh you know i think it's going to lead
to our ruin as a country if we don't
have some law and order again
senator tell me because i was reading an
op-ed you wrote earlier this summer
about demilitarizing the police i think
that was in the headline
and you had said i think it was in july
you weren't necessarily such a huge fan
of the
the notion of sending in federal law
enforcement
into cities like chicago and portland
have you shifted given what's happened
over the past couple of months or are
you still there
i think the best uh law enforcement is
local
i do feel sorry for these people in
these cities run by democrat mayors who
aren't doing anything i mean
to call riding and burning the
courthouse you know a summer of love
like the mayor in seattle did
to let people occupy you know huge
blocks
there is a role for the federal
government to protect federal uh
buildings
and there's also a role for the the
national guard but has to be typically
called out by the governor
so it's been rare in our country and i
think it's fortunately rare that uh
the we actually have troops in our
cities and i don't want to see that
again
um i think george bush the first george
bush did call troops out during the
rodney king rights and
in los angeles i think it has been done
in the past yeah but my preference would
be that law enforcement be done at a
local level
and that's still my preference but i
think there is a role when there's
pandemonium
and up in a completely lawless state to
have a superior show of force such as
the national guard and putting down a
riot
um i think frankly in louisville when
this when the decision is made on
whether or not um there'll be
prosecution of the police that were
involved with fiona taylor
um there's already threats of violence
people talk about burning the city down
and i don't want to see you know
louisville's the biggest city in
kentucky i don't want to see it burn
like
portland and minneapolis and all the
others and so the best way to do that is
to have a large show of force
and hopefully you don't have to use the
force but a show of force can be a
deterrent
and so i am for the national guard
preemptively getting involved and being
available and being on every corner
uh when that when that is called out
because i do think that
uh if we don't uh you know the threats
of burning louisville are very real
interesting so you have more personal
fears now right um i want to talk
to you about how you were attacked as
you left the rnc last week
as scary as the video was to watch i i
personally
got i think i got chills really when i
heard that you were in your hotel room
and you could hear people
talking about where you were
and it made you realize that there were
protesters looking for you from
inside your hotel room is that is that
the case
yeah we we did a great deal to try to
avoid getting in this melee we went to
the exit and the secret service told us
and we could see the mayhem
we could see large mobs of people
chasing people down
outside just outside the white house
gates it was just horrendous
so we took a bus with a police escort to
the trump hotel which is farther away
than our hotel was
but we still had to somehow get back to
our hotel we then took an uber but the
police had blocked the streets and so
the uber couldn't get us
they got us two blocks from our hotel
but two big city blocks
and as we made it past most of the first
block we got a few jeers
nothing significant but then someone
said hey we've got rand paul trapped
and they all descended on us i mean it
was like the sewers were emptying
everybody from everywhere came around
us and we had literally probably a
hundred people or more surrounding us
pushing in on us
and we'd fortunately found two policemen
and the two policemen
you know were very brave but they were
outnumbered you know 50 to one
and so we were very very concerned
throughout the entire ordeal even when
more police came
we were concerned that the police could
be overrun so
yeah this has got to stop senator one of
the things that was shouted at you
as you left the rnc was say her name
we've heard
we've heard protesters make that demand
many times
it's a reference to demanding that law
enforcement and others say the names of
black people who've died at the hands of
police
and i guess and it's been pointed out
these protesters didn't know not only
have you actually spoken with brianna
taylor's family but
you introduced the justice for brianna
taylor act
um and your statement says this is meant
to prohibit no knock warrants moving
forward
where is that i know you just introduced
that this summer yeah we introduced it
after talking with her family but i've
been an opponent of no not grades for as
long as i've been in public office
and so we have talked about criminal
justice reform i'm a
co-sponsor and author with uh democrat
co-sponsors on two dozen criminal
justice bills so i've been very active
in this space
that's the irony of these people who are
really intent just on violence they have
no clue and don't care about
actually changing politics and if they
did would they be yelling at people
instead of
registering people to vote you know if
they cared about you know our country
wanted to be a better place they would
have a voting registration table and
sign people up to vote
you know and then they would try to
appeal to the congress but they wouldn't
try to corner people in congress and
threaten them
and uh you know terrorize people but
yeah the briona taylor act is something
that
it would end the no knock raids and
might have prevented the tragedy from
happening
um but these people have no idea you
know and
so the bill we have introduced it'll be
sent to a committee
it's likely been sent to a committee and
we introduced it at the time when we
were discussing police reform in general
we also introduced it as an amendment to
the republican bill that the democrats
refused to hear
which is also sort of a problem i wasn't
particularly in love with the republican
bill i thought it could have been better
but i voted to get on it so we could try
to amend it every democrat voted no
because frankly they like all this chaos
and they would rather
this be their campaign but i think joe
biden
and i think also kamala harris they need
to
denounce these people you know this is
their base these these
marauding people in our in our streets
are all supporters of joe biden he he
did i mean i think he
in his mind at least i think if we were
to ask him he would say he pretty
forcefully denounced violence on tuesday
and i think if you were to talk to some
of these anarchist types i mean i don't
know about you i've talked to some of
these
anarchist types over the years they
don't support any politician they
support just burning it all down i don't
know if they would say they support joe
biden do you
no absolutely they would who do you
think the
organizers of black lives matter support
they support joe pine they hate donald
trump with a passion and they do support
joe biden
so the thing is is he could easily
renounce the support
of any of the people involved with this
but he won't because
black lives matter is a constituent
group a part of the base of joe biden
and i frankly think that he won't
because i think he actually supports
what they're doing
do you think the officers in the
shooting of brianna taylor
should be arrested and what do you think
should happen to them i think that you
know
that'll have to be worked out by people
who know all the details of the case
and i don't know so frankly i think it's
going to be decided by the attorney
general of kentucky
who has seen all the the police reports
and all that and it's
i think it's wrong of anybody to make a
judgment uh uh as serious as that
not knowing the information so someone
would have the information
i do think that the most important thing
is the policy and the policy can put
good people in a bad position
so let's say you're a brand new
policeman on the force and you're told
to go break down a door at two in the
morning
you know they shout police but breaking
someone's door down people on the other
side are startled
and the people on the other side usually
are drug dealers and in this case
apparently they everybody involved in
this is involved with the drug trade
somehow
but when they did break the door down
someone shoots and the police shoot back
so really the problem is putting police
in this position
and putting people in this position and
the best way to save lives is just not
to do no not grades and so that's what
my bill does
and uh but doesn't get involved with the
specifics of this case
because i frankly just don't know uh you
know all enough of the specifics to make
that decision
finally senator um we've talked a lot
about you know police
and police reform and the violent
protests and i'm wondering
you know do you think president trump
should do something
different than what he's been doing in
order to calm things we've heard mr
biden say
that he adds fuel to every fire and that
things would be much safer with him
um and that the president's just blaming
crap mayors for the violence and
destruction meanwhile this is all
happening
you know under under a president trump
administration
do you do you think president trump
should do anything differently
crime including murder rape and all of
these things
are under the jurisdiction of state
local officials the president has really
nothing to do with crime
and so when you look at these cities
what you find is the top 10 cities with
the highest murder rate per capita
are all democrats if you look at the
cities that have had the major problems
chicago
portland minneapolis louisville and our
state all run by democrats for
50 solid years not one republican so
it's kind of hard to say
it has anything to do with republicans
or donald trump
and everybody wants to say oh yeah the
people that are coming in the restaurant
attacking you and your wife and taking
your food throwing your food on the
floor
and uh physically preventing you from
moving oh those are that's donald
trump's fault
that's the most ridiculous thing i've
ever heard because how is it the fault
of somebody
who says what he wants to do for the
country and then the other side reacts
in violence
the violence going on in our cities is
all coming from the left
senator rand paul thank you so much for
your time thank you
[Music]
this is jimmy fella with your fox news
commentary coming up
the coronavirus put the economy in
recession
prompting congress to spend three
trillion dollars
most americans got direct payments many
small businesses got loans they don't
have to pay back and millions of people
out of work
got extra unemployment money but that
dried up
and then came gridlock and when
lawmakers couldn't agree on more
financial aid president trump said
he was fed up therefore i'm taking
executive action
he signed an order august 8th we're
going to save american jobs and provide
relief to the american workers he
offered more extended unemployment
and a way for a lot of americans to
bring home more
pay from work by cutting a tax the
payroll tax
and starting this week companies across
america are allowed to start doing that
it's something that democrats and some
republicans disagree with
saying it only helps people who have
jobs and
millions don't right now another
criticism
it's not really a tax cut
correct so so this is a tax deferral is
what it is
edward lawrence is a fox business
correspondent
the government the irs collects 12.4
percent
uh from everybody for um uh
social security now half of that is paid
by your work
half is paid by the employee uh 2.9
percent for medicare
a half again paid by work half by the
employee
this focuses on the social security
payment that's made and and basically
takes the workers portion of that
which is half a 6.2 percent and says you
could defer that you don't have to take
that and out of your paycheck
today you can defer that now the
payments will have to be paid back
uh from january through april and and
that's sort of the rub in a lot of this
and why some companies
are not opting in to do this and
companies would have to opt
in to get this done right so this is up
to companies
whether or not they want to let their
employees take this deferral
that's correct uh and i can tell you
that the 1.3 million workers already
working for the federal government are
going to get this the federal government
has made the decision that they are
going to take this
and defer those payments uh you know the
president though
has said and white house economic
advisor larry kudlow
that they will try and make this
permanent this deferral so they will
never have to be
paid back but again that uncertainty is
causing some companies to really say
wait a minute maybe we don't want to
offer this to our employees yeah let's
go back to what you're talking about how
they want to make it permanent the
president
doesn't have the power to make it
permanent does he i mean
that's just have help from congress and
that's that's really
tough right now that's correct yeah they
would need lawmakers in congress to come
to a deal
on a bill and put that bill forward in
order to make these uh payroll tax
deferrals
permanent however the larry kudlow the
white house economic advisor is making
the case that if the president or if the
republicans win
uh both the senate the house and the
presidency that would be much easier
uh to get that deferral done to made
permanent
also he says at the end of this year
kudlow saying the end
by the end of this year the president
will sign another executive order
deferring the defer to the deferral
so that means that the president will be
able to continually defer this
until we can get a deal is what his
argument is
with democrats republicans whoever's
lawmakers that make up the congress
in order so folks don't have to pay this
back all right now
not everybody would be eligible for this
even if companies allow you
to defer you have to be making a certain
amount or less correct
that's correct your bi-weekly uh total
pre-tax would be four thousand dollars
or
that's two thousand dollars a week
pre-tax and it comes out to basically an
annual salary
of under of one hundred and four
thousand dollars and those are the only
folks who would be eligible
uh to get this deferral all right so if
you make over that
even if your employer says you can you
can't correct
so what happens in january let's say
i defer and i have a couple thousand
dollars
extra that come in my paycheck what
happens january 1st
in supposedly unless there's more
referrals
assuming there's no more deferrals by
the president assuming that it's not
made permanent
um you would then have to pay back your
regular
you would be paying your regular social
security tax and then some portion
of the deferral amount um so you would
see less in your paycheck starting
january 1st it has to be paid
from january through april because
starting on may 1st
there's going to be a penalty uh if that
is not paid back that full tax
a penalty if you'd oh all right so but
but again
if your company's the one who's dealing
with all this
assuming i mean they're the ones that
took the money out and then they would
be the ones
uh that mean that didn't take the money
out right and deferred it they would be
also the ones though that would claw it
back so you wouldn't have to actually
write a check personally right
no you would just not see it in your in
your paycheck so your weekly paycheck
would be less than normal
to pay the extra amount of the deferred
but here's where it gets
kind of fuzzy dave because what happens
if you're an employee now
but on january 1st you are no longer an
employee of that particular company
this is the uncertainty that the reason
some companies aren't doing this because
there's no clear guidance from the irs
as to yes the company's on the hook
for that money or you as a person or is
on the hook and it follows you around
um i mean what if you're on a point in
january i mean then you
exactly wow there's just no clear
guidance going forward if
if that scenario comes up where you're
no longer an employee
the other thing that i i know that it's
not
easy especially for a large company
to implement something immediately this
was signed by the president
a few weeks ago the guidance from the
irs didn't go out
to specify how to do this until last
week correct
yeah friday actually it went out friday
so
so how quickly can they actually
implement a deferral in the payroll
systems
well some companies i mean some
companies have advanced software and
they can just
not collect that particular tax other
companies small businesses
for example might not be able to pay
that amount of money to get that
advanced software so it could take a
little bit of time now i don't think
it's going to be the same kind of time
that we're talking about with states
trying to fix their unemployment
insurance and get that extra benefits in
there it's not as archaic
as that but you know it could take a
week or so for companies
to sort of get this right now there's a
lot of criticism
about okay what would happen to social
security because you're
defunding it initially for a few months
right and that's exactly right and and
this is where the white house in one
voice has basically said that they're
going to make sure that social security
is whole
so somehow either move money from the
general fund which is what i've heard
treasury secretary steve mnuchin say
they can move money from the general
fund into social security
i've also heard white house economic
advisor larry kudlow say that they will
absolutely make sure that social
security is whole this will not affect
social security now if this payroll tax
reduction sounds familiar
it's because back in 2011 president
obama
signed one into law that was passed by
congress
not a deferral that had to be paid back
it expired in 2013 but
it wasn't as big as this one it cut the
payroll tax from 6.2
to 4.2 percent saving the average worker
about 19
a week now to the other part of the
president's executive order mentioned
earlier
it offers another round of extra
unemployment assistance
after the 600 bucks a week that many
republicans thought was too much
expired at the end of july this new
round is about half that
so basically on expanded unemployment
benefits the
states would have to apply to fema
because the money's actually coming
from fema it's being redirected so it's
it's an opt-in
situation so 41 states so far have
applied and been approved
for this extra unemployment benefits of
those states six of them arizona
louisiana missouri montana
which is giving a full four hundred
dollars extra texas and tennessee
are sending those extra benefits right
now now it's three hundred dollars
additional from the federal government
then states can choose
to add on another one hundred dollars a
week
uh in extra meaning an actual four
hundred dollars a week in extra benefits
and again i said montana is the only
state so far
has been approved and is actually
sending out those extra benefits
what about fema's funding i mean it is
hurricane season exactly this is coming
from the emergency relief uh the
administration feels like there is
enough funding in fema
to cover this uh and as you see that not
all of the states have applied for this
but this is just a stop gap to try and
come to some agreement
with democrats going forward uh for some
covet relief package the fourth
relief package which is at a stalemate
right now now treasury secretary steve
mnuchin faced a lot of questions about
that
at a house hearing on tuesday i believe
a bipartisan agreement
still should be reached and would
provide substantial funds
for schools testing vaccines
ppp for small businesses continued
enhanced unemployment benefits
and the president by a new executive
order wants to offer people who can't
pay their rent further protections from
evictions it's estimated
about a third of americans have missed
either a rent or a mortgage payment
during this crisis
seven months since the first case was
discovered on our shows
the course of this coronavirus continues
to be devastating so congressman james
clyburn and his fellow democrats want to
spend a lot more than republicans do
it it is going nowhere at this point
what's what's happening now
is that uh the chief of staff mark
meadows is working with republicans in
the senate
and they're going to put forth a bill at
some point this week
that has 500 billion dollars uh in it
and that's going to have
things like testing uh some money for uh
schools to reopen
it's also going to have direct payments
to americans on the expanded
unemployment benefits
among some other things but basically
just what's needed not the extra
fluff and so it's 500 billion dollars
they're going to try and get it passed
through the senate
once that happens that's a starting
point according to the chief of staff
mark meadows from where they can go
up to democrats they don't want to start
where the house bill was the heroes act
and come down because democrats at this
point
have not been willing to come down off
their uh their number they're saying 2.2
trillion
is as much as they'll come down on that
yeah well one of the big problems
is when it comes to trying to figure
this out
house democrats want to spend a lot of
money on
aid to state and local governments
republicans don't want that
exactly you're talking about 914 billion
dollars is what uh
mark meadows says that the house speaker
nancy pelosi wants and she will not come
off that number
is what he's saying and that is just
unacceptable because the white house is
saying hey look we want to know where
that money's going
and what that money's for uh the house
speaker nancy pelosi according to the
white house according to meadows
at this moment is not saying exactly
what that money is for
and that's this is the rub they don't
want to bail out states that have
mismanaged their money like
california with the the pensions that
they've given just
killed their budget new york illinois
they don't want to bail out these states
that have mismanaged
their funding uh just because the
coronavirus is around they want to make
sure that money is targeted
to those actual places where it needs
like overtime for firefighters
over time for for medics the
firefighters that are emts
also getting police over time to handle
some of these riots and the violence
edward lawrence fox business thank you
for joining us
dave thanks for having me i appreciate
it
[Music]
from the fox news podcasts network
subscribe and listen to the trey gowdy
podcast former federal prosecutor and
four-term u.s congressman
from south carolina brings you a
one-of-a-kind podcast
subscribe and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
it's time for your fox news commentary
jimmy
what's on your mind donald trump
famously joked during the 2016 campaign
that he was so popular
he could shoot someone in the middle of
fifth avenue in new york city and get
away with it
critics pointed to the joke as proof
that then candidate trump was running
some kind of a cult
well the truth is he was then and he is
now but the star of the cult isn't trump
it's america and as was the case in 2016
no one in the media seems to be in on
the joke but him here's the thing
donald trump has been selling maximum
strength america since the moment he
came down the escalator and it's a lot
more potent than any of his critics seem
to realize
yes the guy has a weapons great ego and
he leads the league in wild pitches on
twitter
every year but he also has a true
political superpower
and that he's far more in touch with the
average voter than any of his enemies
could ever dream to be
that was the lesson we were all supposed
to have learned from the historic upset
of hillary clinton
highly paid tv analysts prioritize
completely different
issues than blue-collar workers do hence
the result
everyone found so shocking while the
media spent 2016 obsessing over the
trump twitter feed
he knew voters were focused on issues
that directly affected their lives like
a vow to bring back jobs and renegotiate
some of those bad trade deals
trump recognized that voters are a lot
more inspired by a candidate who talks
their country
up especially after eight years of an
administration that used identity
politics to talk it down
which brings us to the race we're in now
like hillary clinton before him
joe biden is going all in on a dopey
social pressure campaign with a slogan
that pitched trump as the enemy in a
fictitious battle for the soul of our
nation
folks make no mistake about it democrats
and their allies in the media have
learned nothing from 2016.
rather than giving voters something to
root for they spent their entire
convention
giving voters someone to root against
they brought out some of the most
respected and influential politicians in
the world
and also john kasich and they doubled
down on the president's character issues
despite the fact that for most voters
that horse left the barn years ago and
it's just as well because the barn would
likely get burnt down at a peaceful
protest if it was anywhere near a
democrat-run city
folks the average american knows
president trump isn't throwing a perfect
rhetorical game
which explains why after four nights of
orange man bad at the dnc
joe biden got zero bump in the polls
donald trump is a better shot at a
second term than anyone realizes because
he's once again going full throttle on
american excellence
vowing during his acceptance speech on
the white house lawn to get the country
off the mat
after it was knocked down by a deadly
pandemic here's the electoral contrast
in a nutshell
unlike the democrats the republicans
aren't bashing america for awful parts
of his history like slavery and
segregation
things we've worked incredibly hard to
overcome i might add rather than asking
voters to focus on the america we were
the president brought out black
supporters like civil rights icon
clarence henderson
who is an instrumental figure in making
us the america we are
which is a place where south carolina
senator tim scott's family could go from
cotton to congress
in one generation senator scott grandson
of a sharecropper
grew up to be the first african-american
elected to both houses of congress
he didn't say we have a perfect country
but at a time when the left is
desperately pushing divisive terms like
white
privilege he pointed out the unique
american privilege
everyone in this country has right now
thanks to the sacrifices of civil rights
forebearers like clarence henderson
tim scott pointed out that his
prosperity was attributable to the
evolution of the southern heart
that allowed voters to judge him by the
content of his character and not the
color of his skin
but most importantly he emphasized above
all else that for all of its flaws
america is a country worth rooting for
something donald trump knows better than
anybody
yes president trump may be the ultimate
showman
but the star of the show is not him it's
the greatest country in the world
and that just so happens to be the
greatest inside joke ever told
be sure to check out fox across america
weekdays from noon to three with me
jimmy fala
at foxnewsradio.com
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news go to
foxnews.com
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes